Now it turns out that this graph does actually have a Hamiltonian path.
And to see this, let's go ahead and start here, and let's come around here and here.
We're going to come over here, here, here, here, here, here, here, and here.
And we have covered every single vertex, as you can see.
Now it turns out that this graph does not have a Hamiltonian cycle.
And, in order to show this, you would actually have to know a bit more math
or exhaustively check every single possibility, which I am not going to do
in this video because it would take far too long.
So I invite you to try and find a Hamiltonian cycle if you doubt that,
but it may take some time.